Cameron Diaz just came out and said we
need to normalize couples sleeping not
only in separate bedrooms but in
separate homes and everyone has been
dragging her for this the only defense I
want to make of Cameron Diaz here is
that Aristocrats have been doing this
forever Aristocrats have been sleeping
in separate bedrooms forever the royal
family sleeps in separate bedrooms the
queen Queen Elizabeth and Prince Philip
would sleep in separate bedrooms there's
something to that I think where the the
disconnect is here is that uh people
sleeping in separate homes is a little
bit clinical I'm reminded of a line from
Robert Frost which is uh from a poem
departmental the line is uh it couldn't
be called ungentle but how thoroughly
departmental and what this comes from I
suspect is not an old aristocratic sense
that we want to have our proper spaces
and you know be together in this very
well-ordered uh high class kind of um
schedule but it comes from a demand for
individualism you know it actually comes
from the totally the opposite the the
old
aristocratic uh order for sleeping and
behavior and living came from the notion
that we don't have really very much
privacy that everything is sort of
public and we don't have a ton of
individualism that we express however we
please but we have duty and we have
honor and we have to behave in a certain
proper way we have to wear certain
clothing and eat dinner at a certain
time and behave in a certain way with
members of the opposite sex up to
including our spouse what Cameron Diaz
is talking about here is expressive
individualism which is I want my own
space I want my own thing and and maybe
my husband can come and visit me when
it's convenient for me that probably not
a great idea separate bedrooms can be
nice because you our spouses always
steal the sheets but uh if if one had to
choose I think it's probably good to
cuddle up next to your honey and uh Tamp
down the individualism that threatens to
destroy our civilization right now go to
P talk.com are you traveling for
Christmas if so P talk has you covered
because they just added international
roaming to over 30 countries that's
right whether you are making calls on a
beach in the Bahamas on the the steps of
Buckingham Palace or at your Villa in
Santorini you can dial away here's the
best part no rate increase Pure Talk
still saves the average family almost
$1,000 a year with plans starting at
just 20 bucks a month Pure Talk is the
gift that keeps on giving they put you
on America's Most Dependable 5G Network
the coverage is second to none stop
dragging your feet switch to Pure Talk a
veteran owned Wireless company with
Simply the Best Us customer service team
now with international roaming to over
30 countries go to Pur talk.com nscw to
make the switch you will also save an
additional 50% off your first month that
is PE
talk.com kwes to start saving on
wireless today Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless last week a staffer for
some democrat
Senator was caught filming I think I'm
the only show in America that did not
post screenshots of this in his show or
on his Twitter page and I don't no one
needs to see the screenshots but it was
pretty gross and uh the staffer then
said that he was being persecuted for
who he loves of course he was not being
persecuted for who he loves I'm not
quite sure that what he was doing in
that video would be described as love uh
he was certainly being persecuted for
How He Loves because that isn't love and
he's if he's trying to love he's doing
it the wrong way and definitely doing it
in the wrong place where he loves I
guess is another issue namely the Senate
Judiciary hearing room so just a week
after that turns out there is another
Congressional sex tape involving a
couple of
fellas this one apparently circulated on
Snapchat last year but for those of us
who are are not in those circles uh
we're only finding out about it now
conveniently after this other sex tape
this is from the story of a user going
by Adam J uh recordings of this were
viewed by semaphor and mercifully not by
all of us uh but semaphor says that the
videos featured a man inside a house
office
building uh doing something alone this
is a family show I'm going to try to
clean it up you know uh he was uh doing
what uh Woody Allen referred to as
sleeping with someone you love uh and
then there was also another one with a
dude with two two men uh engaged in
something unfortunate uh the
participants faces are not visible in
any of this
material and then on top of that on top
of that a slightly different but still
related Scandal Joe Biden's press
secretary Michael L Roo was just forced
out of the White House after he
apparently tried quote tried to take gay
dates to his room on a secure floor of
the hotel where the president was
staying during a NATO Summit in Madrid
so when we say dates we're not talking
about this is a man who had been
cultivating some sort of relationship
over some weeks and months no it was a
guy who like went on an app or something
or met a guy at bar and this this press
secretary for the first lady of the
United States brings some random dude
back to the secured floor where the
president of the United States is
staying uh to go engage in weird stuff
that apparently happens in places other
than the US capital
I I am calling for a complete and total
shutdown of homosexual political
staffers with iPhones until we figure
out what the hell is going on okay I am
a compl complete and total shutdown we
should not be reading this many
headlines within the span of two weeks
at very high levels of the government
that is really weird man what is driving
this this is completely insane behavior
let's start with the most anod of the
behaviors this dude working for Joe
Biden who decides it's a smart idea
during a NATO Summit you're there
working for the first lady you're with
the president you're with the entire
Secret Service and you decide it's a
good idea to pick up some random dude in
a foreign country and go back and do
creepy weird stuff in your hotel room on
a floor with the president what what
kind of Insanity would have to have
taken over your mind and soul to
convince you that was a good idea you're
going to give up a promising political
career with one of the most enviable
jobs in politics you're working right
there for the first family in the White
House and you give that up to do weird
creepy sex stuff with some Rando
Spaniard what has to take over your mind
you you've got a job in the US capital
working for a member of the House of
Representatives or a senator and you
decide it's a really good idea to not
only engage in creepy actions that would
obviously be caused for immediate
termination and actions which are in
themselves extremely humiliating but
you're going to film it and send it
around and you think that's going to be
fine no one's going to trace it back to
you even though you're on camera
committing the actions you the the guy
who was working for the Democrat Senator
he posted all sorts of weird creepy sex
stuff all over his social media not only
after he was hired even before he was
hired he somehow still got the job what
is taking over these people's minds to
convince them to do something not only
that is gross and immoral but that is
just so stupid that's so profoundly
foolish and that is
guaranteed in in the long run to lose
you your job and career and to humiliate
you at the national level I'll give you
the answer I know exactly what it is
we've been talking about it for two
weeks it's porn that's what's doing it
to these people that is what is melting
these people's brains and the reason I
know that is because I read the mailbag
reason I know that is I read surveys and
statistics on porn usage which is 90%
plus among men because I read the
statistics that show that the average
age or the median age of first exposure
to porn is something like 11 and then I
read the mailbag and I hear from people
not only the libs who brag about how
addicted to porn they are but even
conservatives who say I've been
struggling with this since I was a kid
or or a teenager and it's really awful
and I keep trying to fix it and I I
can't most people are are addicted to
this stuff at least among men I hope not
among women but even the rates
apparently of viewership among women
have gone
up and it it melts people's brains it
warps their perception of reality it
like any drug is is just totally warping
their their risk analysis like a like a
crackhead who's trying to score that
they totally ignore risk that they
engage in Reckless dangerous behavior
that almost always redounds to their
disadvantage and there's the they're
literally filming porn in this case
right in in the case of these two dudes
the Senate guy and the Congressional guy
they were the reason I know porn is at
the heart of this is they weren't just
engaging in creepy sex acts in the
capital they were producing pornography
and then they were disseminating that to
other people so it's not even that this
was just uh something they wanted to
keep for their own posterity you know a
little momento of of their romp at the
capital part of whatever was driving
them was the fact that they would be
viewed by other people on a screen how
did this dude in NATO how did this Joe
Biden press secretary meet that random
guy maybe they met at a bar it could be
statistically though what's most likely
is they did it on one of these swipe
apps it's it's a major problem okay
because it is causing people to become
enslaved to one particular desire you
can easily become enslaved to any Vice
and sin if you if you're a Booz hound
and and you drink out of moderation what
happens you think you're really free you
think you're really liberated you can do
whatever you want but in the moment that
you break those bounds of moderation the
moment that you engage in mortal sin and
cultivate that Vice what happens you
become a slave you become owned by that
sin you become a slave to booze or you
could become a slave to drugs or you
could become a slave to gluttony to food
or you become a a slave to Pride to
vanity or in this case you become a
slave to your
lusts and so you do things that any
rational person knows is completely
insane you damage your life you become a
national laughing stock like all of
these guys have you lose your career for
what to do some embarrassing degrading
action on camera for other people how
sad and how pathetic is it how pathetic
is it for us as a country that we have
to talk about sex this much that the
libs will say why are the conservatives
so obsessed with with sex we're not the
ones filming the stuff in the capital
we're not the ones picking up random
dudes while we're press secretary for
Joe Biden we're not the ones changing
all the sexual rules trying to redefine
marriage trying to put dudes in the
women's bathroom trying to put porn in
the hands of kindergarteners we're not
doing that we're the ones saying hey
whoa chill man it's the libs who are the
aggressors in the sexual Revolution it's
the libs who are the aggressors in the
culture war and it's pathetic it's very
shameful for them and it's annoying for
us that we a once great nation
supposedly the global hegemon have to
spend all of our time talking about
genitals it's ridiculous it's sad it's
pathetic there are other things in the
world and if we want to be a great
nation again we're going to need to
focus on some of those things but you
can't focus on those things when your
brain is so melted by porn that that in
in our nation's capital we have to spend
our time investigating who is filming
pornography in the Senate hearing room
or we we need to spend time
investigating what really is a man and
what really is a woman so that we can
have a national debate over whether
dudes should be allowed into your little
daughter's bathroom at a at a public
pool pathetic no Nation will be great if
that is what we have to
do but but the problem is you do have to
address some of these things because if
we don't understand basic facts of life
if we if we can't agree on basic facts
of human nature we can't have a poity we
can't talk to one another we can't
deliberate we can't even speak we don't
we don't even speak the same language
anymore and if we don't overcome our
most basic appetites and passions then
we won't be capable of rational thought
or a rational will or being a great
nation absolutely pathetic man what a
great clip that was now whoa hold up
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nlls YouTube channel and we will see you
next time